you
[Music]
alright hey everybody it's good to be
back from the Thanksgiving break many
things to talk about including yes
Donald Trump faking an orgasm in public
at a rally it is very weird video I
recommend getting the kids out of the
room I have totally new graphics and
this will be cool these are actually I
can edit these let's see they have they
exist in a couple different formats here
is one of them and I can actually edit
these so as people sign up I can go in
oh that's for later actually we don't
want that yet as people sign up I can go
in and for example change the number of
new members to two and then when I do
that I think the prog the progress bar
goes up but I will keep it at zero for
now because that's where we are but this
is cool and then I think that the sign
up images graphics the alert box so to
speak is up at the top there let's see
if I test it oh there it is it does work
carbon forms has just subscribed I think
we could actually make that even a
little bit bigger that'll work for us
very well so very exciting things live
on Twitch and live on YouTube it's great
to see everybody and we have so much to
talk about I will show you the video
weightless things are happening here I
will show you the video of Donald Trump
faking the orgasm it's really weird
we're going to talk about that I will be
talking about George Conway for the
first time appearing to publicly go
against his wife Kelli Ann Conway that's
going to be interesting
I also a Donald Trump tweeted that this
guy congressman Doug Collins did a great
job over the weekend defending Trump and
so I assumed it had to be crazy and it
is I found the video and it is
absolutely it's total gibberish and it's
such Jewish that I actually transcribed
what he says for us and we're going to
look at that a little bit later and then
also very disturbing video of Mark
Zuckerberg just not willing to tell us
what it is
that he discussed with Donald Trump in a
meeting he didn't even want but he
didn't even want the meeting to be
public and now we know that the meeting
happened and he doesn't answer what went
on I also might look at polling Pete
Budaj has been
serging let's see if we can actually
zoom out so you can see this there it is
Pete Budaj edge with a pop right there
we will talk about what might be behind
that I also want to talk about I think
that my audience is not paying attention
to me and just up voting or down voting
based on titles and I'm going to talk
about that in a little bit this video
oops I accidentally disliked my own
video I didn't mean to do that
so we're going to talk about that as
well but we will start with the Trump
thing momentarily I will answer
questions the super chat over on YouTube
and via highlighted messages over on
Twitch and also via twitch prime
subscriptions people asking why our
episodes don't premiere on Twitch
anymore twitch is removing premieres I
believe as of December 12 and we figured
since they're getting rid of it we're
just not going to keep using that that
functionality since it's going away
anyway thanks to met Toph C hosts for
signing up for twitch prime carbon forms
for signing up for twitch prime and
Graham strong for signing up with twitch
prime I very much appreciate it and a
super chat is enabled use the dollar
sign over on YouTube at the bottom of
the chat window in order to send a super
chat and we will I will answer those
questions here's the deal here's Donald
Trump faking an orgasm on live TV this
is actually from a few weeks ago you
might remember the names Peter struck
and Lisa Paige these were two FBI
workers FBI employees who had an affair
and ultimately Lisa Paige left the FBI
and Donald Trump and Peter struck rather
was let go and Donald Trump often likes
to cite them as evidence of wrongdoing
as evidence of the Russia probe being a
witch-hunt or you know whatever and this
time Donald Trump chose to reenact I
guess a fake conversation or some text
messages between Lisa Paige and Peter
struck and in doing it around the 45
second mark
Trump appears to be impersonating Lisa
Paige having an orgasm now I will I will
warn you this is ugly this is very very
ugly and I don't I don't think children
should see this this is really not good
but let's take a listen to it together
and it's it's pretty grim do that oh
hold on a second
was 19 minutes after the oath of office
months earlier Peter struck remember he
and his lover
Lisa Paige water group she's going to
win ten million to one she's gonna win
and I'm telling you Peter
I'm telling you Peter she's gonna win
Peter oh here he goes he's starting to
work up
[Music]
I love you Peter I love you too Lisa at
least hello Lisa
Lisa oh god I love you Lisa yeah quite
an actor right I mean this is a guy who
really should be he I don't even know
that the presidency is his calling I
think an act that actually he should be
acting and then of course the crowd
going completely we've got it insurance
policy Lisa will get that son of a [ __ ]
out so obviously you know the idea of
having a president that behaves this way
is you know it's just a complete and
total joke but what's more concerning to
me actually is the crowd's reaction you
know the the idea that there are
thousands of people there but presumably
many more people millions of people
around the country who are okay
having a president like this who behaves
in this way who comports themselves in
this way and yeah the crowd going wild
here and I'm telling you Peter
I'm telling you Peter she's gonna win
Peter oh I love you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I mean you know the the cheering is
strange and of course you know all the
normal jokes apply Donald Trump
certainly would know what it's like to
be in a room when there are fake orgasms
that's no surprise whatsoever all of
that normal stuff but this is this you
know the idea that a president Lisa page
in the end is a public servant was a
federal employee was was doing her job
and a president not only faking an
orgasm during an event right but doing
it all in service to attacking a public
servant is disturbing and yeah as people
are pointing out it doesn't seem
difficult to entertain the sorts of
people that go to these Trump rallies
that's for sure and a a very very
diverse crowd so typically last that's
actually funny that people are pointing
that out last livestream we did we
happen to overlap with a little bit of
Trump's Magga rally or a CagA rally as
they are now calling them in Florida and
this position right here over Trump's
left shoulder it's typically reserved
for a black man at Trump rallies and
even at Republican Republican events in
general and here apparently they didn't
have somebody here so they weren't able
to do to get that get that set up very
very diverse people a group of people on
stage as you can see it is Minnesota
after all so anyway that's what went on
and we'll talk about it a little bit
more tomorrow and really the Lisa page
thing is actually the big part of it
that that deserves the most discussion
and analysis because it's horrible
what's going on with her let me address
a Super chat from read the night one who
sends us a ten dollar super chat on
YouTube saying I was watching ring of
fire saying that the judge warns Trump
to turn in the tax returns but Trump
keeps evading tax returns until the end
of Tuesday does this mean Trump will be
arrested by force I don't know exactly
what you're saying but I know Donald
Trump is not going to be arrested by
force that's that's not going to happen
I would not hold my breath for that
whatsoever okay over on twitch let me
say thank you to
a beauty shark for subscribing with
twitch Prime and also thanks to Giselle
or she soul for subscribing for three
months with Prime with the message I'm
from Europe I enjoy following US
politics through your channel thank you
very much I appreciate that all right so
there's Trump faking the orgasm let's go
to some other stuff Mark Zuckerberg is
the founder of Facebook and he is
increasingly someone that I don't see as
a particularly good faith actor in the
battle against actual fake news buy it
by that I don't mean news that Trump
doesn't like I mean actual fake news
disinformation propaganda campaigns he
increasingly seems pretty much
unconcerned we saw how he imploded in
the testimony before the House of
Representatives before a committee there
were congresswoman Alexandria Cassio
Cortes made made him look not only bad
but just clueless about what Facebook
policy even is okay so in any case it
turns out that Mark Zuckerberg had a
meeting with Donald Trump it was kept
off of Trump's public schedule Facebook
did not announce that the meeting took
place eventually NBC reported hey
Zuckerberg and Trump met so Gayle King
on CBS this morning this morning asked
Mark Zuckerberg what was discussed
during that meeting and the non-answers
make me sort of physically uncomfortable
actually it's it's it's uncomfortable to
watch take a look it was reported later
that you had dinner with the president
of the White House what was the nature
of the meeting can you say sure I mean
we talked about a number of things that
were on his mind and that's of the
topics that you read about in the news
around we talked about things on Trump's
mind and things that were in the news
okay you some very clear mark thank
around our work the dinner was not
disclosed by the White House and only
became public after the fact through
news reports it came as President Trump
was openly discouraging Facebook from
banning political ads listen people
would say the optics weren't good did he
try to lobby you in any way no
that's that I think some of the stuff
that people talk about or think gets
discussed and these discussions are not
really how okay how that works
I also Mark Zuckerberg should stop doing
interviews I think is the conclusion of
respect that it was a private dinner
Brennan's yeah so listen the the private
dinner thing I understand that but of
course it's not just that it was private
you tried to keep it a secret altogether
thanks to gender ik eighty-nine for
giving out five community subs over on
Twitch I appreciate that very very much
and yes for people asking we are taking
questions of the super chat over on over
on YouTube so there's the Mark
Zuckerberg thing let's say I think at
this point it's very clear I mean
Zuckerberg knows where his bread is
buttered Zuckerberg does not have an
interest as Facebook does not have an
interest in keeping political ads off if
they don't stick to the facts it's just
not his concern and by that I don't mean
it shouldn't be I mean it's not he's not
concerned about it and whatever was
discussed with Donald Trump I don't know
we don't know we may never know but
what's abundantly clear is that this is
this is a platform that I understand why
many in my audience are increasingly
leaving increasingly abandoning and
we're going to have more coverage of
that tomorrow as well and yeah I mean
the the the the mealy-mouthed
uncertainty is is very transparent like
this is just not looking good with the
president of the White House what was
the nature of the meeting can you say
sure I mean we talked about a number of
things that were on his mind and and
some of the topics that you've read
about in the news around around our work
yeah anyway so it is uh it is it is
pretty cringe-worthy I I don't really
know what else to make of it other than
whatever you imagine is going on behind
the scenes probably is going on and more
than likely there is going to be that
whatever was discussed during that
meeting between Mark Zuckerberg and
Donald Trump is likely to play a role in
the 2020 presidential
action we you know we'll know more as
time goes on but that is seems
abundantly clear to me at this point in
time okay next I saw Donald Trump tweet
earlier today
great job by congressman Doug Collins of
Georgia over the weekend in representing
the Republican Party and myself against
the impeachment hoax so I saw this and I
thought if Trump liked the performance
it must be terrible but that did not
properly prepare me for the absurdity of
this appearance that congressman Doug
Collins did on Fox News Sunday now try
to follow along but I I've already
transcribed this very bizarre word salad
and we're actually going to put the text
up on the screen but first just listen
to it and see if you can make any sense
out of what he's saying so I do not
spend dollars don't need to spend in the
Ukraine because of corruption it was
still there okay this is an issue let me
just have to get a thought experiment
there just just bear with me for a
minute if you believe that the President
had used the power of his office to try
to get Ukraine to interfere with our
elections if you believe that would that
be an impeachable offense I do not
believe it so I'm not gonna answer a
hypothetical and which is designed to
simply say that the president did
something proper Chris he did nothing
improper there was nothing about a
problematic giving aid to another
country in which you're talking about
corruption which he's required to do by
law and it just so happened that a
presidential candidate son who was
getting in a massive amount of money
from a company that had been under
investigation in which even other
witnesses that have been favorable quote
to the Democrats in the investigation
have said needed to be looked at this is
a problem of overall proportion but
there's nothing here to find it wrong
and this is the thing we're gonna move
okay all right so I actually transcribed
that and we'll put it up on the screen I
mean it is it is a word salad like no
word salad I recall ever ever seeing
so that's but let me make sure we can
all see this I do not believe it so that
I'm not going to answer a hypothetical
in which is designed to simply say that
the president did something improper
Chris he did nothing improper
there's nothing about a problematic
giving aid to another country in which
you're talking about corruption which
he's required to do by law and he just
so happened that a presidential
candidates son who is getting in a
massive amount of money from a company
that had been under investigation in
which me even other witnesses that have
been favorable quote to the Democrats in
the investigation have said needed to be
looked at
that's one sentence this is a problem of
overall proportion but there's nothing
here that the President did wrong and
this is the thing that we're going to
move forward on if that is not a word
salad a meaningless word salad then I
don't know why I have never seen one and
I don't even know what I mean listen I
can tell that he's saying Trump did
nothing wrong that part is clear to me
but then I went back and said what did
Trump say again
great job by cut Doug Collins of Georgia
over the weekend in representing the
Republican Party and myself against the
impeachment hoax yes extremely well done
I think my favorite part here is there's
nothing about a problematic giving aid
to another country in which you're
talking about corruption which he's
required to do by law so I mean I guess
really this entire sentence is my
favorite part very very odd and no
surprise I guess that Donald Trump
absolutely loves it let's just take a
look at what else Trump has been
tweeting many Mike Bloomberg that's
actually pretty funny many Mike
Bloomberg has instructed his third-rate
news organization not to investigate him
or any Democrat but to go after
president Trump only the failing New
York Times thinks that is okay because
their hatred and bias are so great that
they can't even see straight
okay retweeting CNBC just landed in the
United Kingdom heading to London for
NATO meetings tomorrow prior to landing
I read the Republican
report on the impeachment hoax great job
radical left has no case
read the capital T transcripts shouldn't
even be allowed can we go to the Supreme
Court to stop you know unfortunately
it's his Supreme Court increasingly and
and it there's a chance that if given
the opportunity they would intervene the
Fed should lower rates there is almost
no inflation and loosen making us
competitive with other nations and
manufacturing will soar at least he
didn't put SOR E dollar is very strong
relative to others
manufacturers are being held back by the
strong dollar which is being propped up
by the ridiculous policies okay so yeah
when it's convenient he praises the
Federal Reserve otherwise he goes
against them just for kicks let's watch
a few minutes of Lou Dobbs which I
haven't seen a new book out already
higher in the Amazon bestseller list
then the so-called anonymous book
they're joining us tonight a man not
anonymous Doug Wead adviser to two
presidents presidential historian author
of the new bestseller inside Trump's
White House it's loud today and done
congratulations on the book we want to
tell you we requite to you exactly and
how much fun was this to write buddy
would know it's fun for me to even tell
you but when they finally approved it
and I walk in the Oval Office he doesn't
even say hello he doesn't shake my hand
he I walk in the Oval Office and he's
got these papers this is my private
correspondence with kim jong hoon they
don't want you to have this they tell me
not to let you see this but i'm going to
let you have it you can't copy it you
can't keep it but you can read it and
that's how it started
that's great wow just absolutely
heartwarming story yeah so I guess this
is what's going I don't really watch
this oh and look up next dr. Sebastian
Gorka yeah this is not a channel i watch
I don't even know if I have this channel
but apparently this is what Trump like
this and this is what they do alright so
there's that next I am going all ins
thing we got the Trump fake orgasm thing
yeah okay I want to talk about this next
but let me do a few thank-yous before I
move on thanks to Val McLin Chi
for subscribing for five months in a row
at tier 1 on twitch I appreciate that
and thanks to Euro edding eroding hmm
subscribed with twitch Prime I also want
to say thanks to Luis GABA shado or as
non Argentinians would say Caballero who
has signed up on our website and now we
have these new graphics so now I can
actually go in and if you look right
above my head when I hit save we get a
progress bar boom there we go that
progress bar moves up as people sign up
which is very very exciting we do have
so this is we had a big Black Friday
membership special and as of right now
how many people used it to 12 so 212
people used that code last 2019 on Black
Friday that is a much bigger discount
than we normally offer on memberships
that I guess it's like 60 something
percent off it drops a $60 membership to
$20.19 get it 2019 the last special of
2019 and it'll drop a $6 a month
membership to two dollars and two cents
so take advantage of that one I am up
for opening up the phones the target for
today is 15 new members and the phones
will open and we also have these cool
graphics which is which is great we're
still tweaking them a little bit but
they are big improvement over the
previous graphics I am taking questions
via super super chat over on youtube
feel free to send them in using the
dollar sign at the bottom of the chat
window ok let's talk about this tweet
that we have on screen
Kellyanne Conway is an advisor to the
president George Conway is a Republican
lawyer and Kelly Ann's husband Kelly Ann
defends Donald Trump all the time
whereas George Conway criticizes Trump
all the time but up until now they have
basically stayed out of each other's way
this is as far as I know the first
direct Trump related contradiction or
response from George Conway
Kellyanne Conway Kellyanne Conway
tweeting watch sleepy Joe is creepy Joe
we need ukraine's help to defeat this
guy and George Conway of course
accurately pointing out your boss
apparently thought so I don't know if
this is the beginning of an upcoming
divorce or what it is but let's take a
look at the video that was tweeted and
by the way you know I sit on the stand
and it get hot I got Ilana I got hairy
legs that turned that that that that
that turned about blonde in the Sun and
the kids used to come up and reach in
the pool and rub my leg down I was
trained and then watch the hair come
back up again this girl loves this so I
learned about roaches I learned about
kids jumping on my lap and I'd love kids
jumping on my lap and I tell you what
yeah this is bad I would stop telling
these stories for sure but to
kellyanne's point if trump was so
convinced that this guy was beatable
then I don't know why he went and did
the entire Ukraine thing that's very
very strange I don't I don't know what
to make of that but anyway I guess this
leads us into polling right yeah why how
does Joe Biden end up telling these
stories that's what I don't understand
let's look at polling okay Joe Biden not
doing so well Joe Biden was here on May
11th let's see if I can set this up
better for you Joe Biden was here on May
11th around 40% and then a big decline
and then it's basically just been up and
down up and down up and down and Joe
Biden now down from I guess Oh
this was the day of the last debate and
since that day it's basically just been
down for Joe Biden so that's not going
particularly well Elizabeth Warren
declining from a high of nearly 27% she
now is down to 14 and Pete Budaj edge is
very close now Bernie has been
relatively steady the last several weeks
but has also dropped down from about 20
to 16 and Pete Budaj
continuing to climb our Biden supporters
going to Budaj
ideologically that makes a lot more
sense it's hard for me to imagine
Berni or a Warren supporter saying I'm
gonna go to Buddha judge but needless to
say Pete Buddha judge is mounting a
campaign which I don't like I mean I'm
I'm a progressive and I want someone who
is more progressive people who to judge
I don't I don't find to be a progressive
on on really almost any issue I mean
okay you know he says basically the
right things on a lot of social issues
abortion and LGBT rights etc but on
health care it's not been good on
tuition free college it's it's not it's
been not good in a few different ways so
I'm not a Buddha judge guy but Buddha
judge also doing well in some early
states very white states admittedly
Buddha judge in Iowa
winning and and actually winning by
quite a bit in two recent polls although
we don't have one from the last couple
of weeks
New Hampshire Buddha judge has been
doing well but in the latest poll Bernie
has taken the lead again New Hampshire
is early but it's actually less
important in the grand scheme of things
for securing the nomination it's very
few delegates and it can be a signal of
momentum but I tend not to put too much
stock into what happens in New Hampshire
although some people put significant
stock into it in Nevada Buddha judge not
doing well he's polling eight he is very
far behind in fourth place behind Biden
Warren and Sanders and very similarly in
South Carolina Buddha judge just way
behind he has half the support of the
third-place candidate who's Bernie
Sanders and Bernie has you know about a
third of the support of the first place
candidate who is Joe Biden so it's still
very very early but there is no question
that nationally Pete Buddha judge
surging and I asked on the broadcast
show today what do you think is behind
this and I'm curious to hear from folks
if people want to send super chats are
highlighted messages on YouTube and
twitch respectively about this I'm glad
to read them and see what's on your mind
let me say thank you or I've got a few
other people to thank here let me say
thanks to John delehanty and also
Elzbieta Marciniak for signing up on my
way
site that gets us to three of 15 new
members for opening up the phone lines
and three of 30 there it is we've got
our new graphics and we are seeing the
we maybe we need a different shade of
blue as the as the bar fills in no maybe
it's not distinct enough maybe that's a
change that could be made in any case
you will see that be filled in hopefully
all the way to the top and off screen as
folks continue to subscribe let me
answer some questions including one from
a user named name withheld via super
chat how much money do you think Kelly
mellon Bakker got for dissing Kamala and
going to Bloomberg I actually don't know
about that story
Kelly Mellon Bakker comma 100 this is
the I'm sorry this is the staffer who
resigned yeah let's take a look at that
real quick that actually I didn't have
her name memorized but that's an
interesting story let's take a look at
that and I'll zoom this out for us
[Music]
Kamala Harris 8 says in resignation
letter I have never seen an organization
treated staff so poorly an aide to
Senator Kamala Harris blasted the
treatment of staff on the California
Democrats presidential campaign in a
resignation letter this month this is my
third presidential campaign and I have
never seen an organization treated staff
so poorly while I still believe that
senator Harris is the strongest
candidate to win in the general election
in 2020 I no longer have confidence in
our campaign or its leadership
she wrote that the treatment of our
staff over the last two weeks was the
final straw in this very difficult
decision it's not acceptable to me that
we encourage people to move from DC to
Baltimore only to lay them off with no
notice with no plan for the campaign
without thoughtful consideration of the
personal consequences to them or the
consequences that their absence would
have on the remaining staff it is
unacceptable that we would lay off
anyone that we hired only weeks earlier
it is unacceptable that with less than
90 days until Iowa we do not have a real
plan to win yeah this I mean listen the
the unfortunate reality let me see how I
can say this in a way that is not I
don't want to try to get any particular
candidate other than Amy Klobuchar our
because we know
stories about her already a lot of these
politicians who we might agree with or
disagree with on the issues they're not
the best people and they don't treat
their staff very well this is really
really common campaign staffers and
congressional staffers and Senate
staffers are notoriously underpaid
overworked and generally speaking not
treated well now I don't want to say
anything in particular but because it's
public amy klobuchar staff has said she
does absolutely horrible things there
was that story about someone who failed
to bring her a fork for her salad and
she took out a comb and started eating
the salad with a comb to shame the
staffer in all sorts of just horrible
stuff and unfortunately this is why I
always say our elected officials
politicians really we should not idolize
and we certainly shouldn't deify them
the way that some people deify an
elected official or a would be elected
official that they really like these are
people often very flawed people like
everybody is they will do some good
things hopefully if we empower them to
do that they often as we know you know
they're more likely to be Psychopaths
they are people who are predisposed to
to get into positions of power I think
are more likely to exhibit some of these
traits where they're not going to treat
staff well and I don't think that this
is surprising now the comb thing with
Klobuchar and laying people off right
after making the move obviously laying
people off after making the move I think
is worse than shaming one person by
eating a salad with a comb so I'm not
equating those things but the point is I
know people in other campaigns and a lot
of the people that you may like on
policy are not the nicest people the
other thing I will also point out and
and I've said this before is that when
you are
I mean does that matter there are people
who will say I don't really care how
individual staff members are treated or
whatever the case may be what I care
about is what are you gonna do for the
largest number of people by being
president treat your staff however you
know I don't know it's hard for me to
really get behind that in any serious
way because I I envision that there is
probably more to the way that these
individuals relate to staffs now on the
other hand someone who as far as I've
read has treated their staff very well
and has low turnover is actually Adam
Schiff Adam Schiff who is running the
House Intelligence Committee and is a
congressman from California originally
from here in Massachusetts I understand
that he stands out in Congress because
he is known to trick you learn at
overworked them I don't think he can do
anything about pay because it's set by
by guidelines but that is that that is
what I have read and who knows if it is
true or if it is not true let me say
thank you to heroes shadow for
subscribing on Twitch let me say thanks
to suck boy for subscribing with twitch
prime as well as stumble biscuit and I
think that that is everybody that gets
me caught up thank you very very much I
also want to say thanks over on our
website to corey Bagley for signing up
for a membership Chris Young Callie
Cara Ninh and Timo Grunwald that gets us
four more members let me update our very
cool graph I love these graphics all
right let's see the the the slider is
gonna pop up here there it goes very
getting very very close to opening the
phone lines let me see if I missed
anyone there I don't believe I did know
that gets me totally caught up okay so
we have seven new members if we get to
15 I'll open the phone lines and if we
get 30 I will commit to another stream
this week despite the fact and it's
gonna be a long week because we are
live-streaming on Wednesday the full
impeachment hearings once again and they
may be they may be very very long
okay I've got to ask for a little bit of
leeway here to sort of explain a
situation to you and it relates to this
video and let me just quickly refresh it
to see how the dislikes are going okay
that the ratio has actually improved a
little bit so listen I did a video today
called Medicare for all isn't happening
soon it's not happening anytime soon and
I want to be like just sickly and
obscenely honest with I am for Medicare
for all
I believe Medicare for all is the best
plan I believe Medicare for all is the
gold standard I believe that the system
that we have is terrible given all of
the options which I've researched and
I've researched many of them and that
includes what happens in Singapore the
Canadian system the Australian system
the system in Argentina where I was born
the Scandinavian systems the system I've
researched all of these systems I still
believe that although no program is
perfect that Medicare for all is the
gold standard and it is my goal but I
also don't just [ __ ] my audience and
so while I will advocate for Medicare
for all and now I will advocate for
candidates who say Medicare for all is
the way and all of that stuff every once
in a while I need to just be realistic
and one of those realistic things is if
you look at what we are up against if
you look at who's up for reelection in
the Senate in 2020 and you look at 2022
and you consider some of the things that
would need to happen for Medicare for
all to actually work financially and
then you realize that some of those
things would be appealed to the supreme
court and the supreme court with people
on it two of whom were selected by
Donald Trump they are not going to go
for so I'm not gonna redo the full ten
minute video that I did but at the very
beginning of this video listen to what I
say start this way today after the
Thanksgiving holiday but if you're
watching on YouTube at least wait please
don't hit the dislike button just yet
consider watching this video first
before you do that right so this video
is ten minutes
and three minutes in it had way more
dislikes than likes and I mean listen
I'm concerned about the movement because
people don't even seem to understand
what I am saying or they seem not to
care now I'm not gonna scroll down
through the comments here I'm going to
do it on my phone because there might
actually be truly horrible like
anti-semitic comments and whatnot that I
don't want popping up on screen but I'm
gonna give you just like a few examples
of the comments that people are leaving
which to me say they're either not
understanding or not watching the video
and and this really concerns me because
I want the movement to succeed and when
I see stuff like this it scares me
let me take a look here where are my how
do I even get access to this on my phone
oh here it is okay here's an example
okay
so David is basically advocating for
centrist policies no I literally say in
the video I'm not suggesting we advocate
for centrist policies I'm not suggesting
we support Joe Biden I'm say in the
video that I'm not doing any of those
things how is that one of the comments
another example this sounds like a Nancy
Pelosi speech go back to being more
progressive I am unequivocally for
medicare-for-all
okay but I also do analysis of the way
the world is not the way I would like it
to be and just wanting it to be a
certain way doesn't make it that way
that's not being defeatist it's
understanding the systems we have to
work with in another example comment
here Bernie can establish a state of
emergency and simply sign
medicare-for-all into law listen I know
that people like to talk about this
people say our system of healthcare is
so bad that it is a form of an emergency
so the president could say we now have a
state of emergency and just sign
medicare-for-all into law it's not gonna
happen guys
okay it's not going to happen it's not
going to happen that's not a realistic
way of getting this past another user
commented I'm not surprised David is
shilling against Medicare
in the video I say medicare-for-all is
the gold standard
I want medicare-for-all we should be
advocating for Medicare for all its it's
merely a reality check I might have just
one more for you here actually some
people seem to understand what's going
on I read one comment that says these
comments show people don't listen to
what he's saying yes correct
another one said the comments are
depressing watch the whole video he
supports Medicare for all he's talking
about strategy he's talking about
reality he's right he's saying it
because people need to know the reality
we need realistic expectations and
knowledge about how the system works so
I'm gonna cover this tomorrow but it is
super depressing because you know I said
during the video if you disagree with me
about the facts that I'm laying out then
tell me which facts I'm wrong about but
simply saying I'm chilling against
Medicare for all come on you know and
and and unfortunately this would be this
would merely be a curiosity if the same
people who are doing this are the people
that we have to count on to be activists
it's very very scary and I cook totally
I see Val eval from Agawam saying you
always ask for more than you want of
course and I criticize Obama in the
video Obama started with it sort of
would be nice to have a public option
and we ended up with no public option we
ended up with you know 20 million new
customers for for-profit insurers if
Obama maybe had started with Medicare
for all maybe we would have already
ended up with a public option under
Obama care so I I'm sick of it and I
will talk about it tomorrow and it's
extremely it's it's disheartening to see
so many people that are on my side
either deliberately or maybe not
deliberately which is arguably even
scarier misunderstand even the arguments
that I'm making name withheld sent a
super chat over on on YouTube saying
what about all how many mountains have
to move for that to happen
yeah listen the reason I'm not there's
obviously obstacles there as well but I
don't believe the obstacles are as big
as they
for medicare-for-all because with free
college for all is not any college and
it's not it's not really a free-for-all
it would be making all existing public
colleges and universities tuition-free
and the mechanisms to do that as
difficult as it may be are far simpler
than those for medicare for all so I
want Medicare for all these black and
white views that people seem to have
it's it's a problem it's a real problem
and I'm trying to think of what so so
tomorrow I want to talk about this on
the show and I was debating what I
should call a video addressing the fact
that I'm concerned about the reactions
to this video and I had the the the
title I'm extremely worried about my
audience I don't want to be click Beatty
but I want to communicate that we do
have a problem but I also don't want to
be patronizing I don't know
I'm open to hearing what what people
think that that video should be called
but it is it is really it's just
disheartening I guess is what what I
will say I'm with you I want Medicare
for all
okay let me say thank you to oh okay let
me do some some thanks Oh super chat
over on YouTube Russell Jones says when
candidates promise Medicare for all and
can't deliver won't it hurt us in the
midterms
I want a candidate to say I am
ultimately for Medicare for all and
here's how we get there
yeah you know there there are candidates
who are using that terminology and it
comes off as insincere in terms of
really wanting Medicare for all so I
don't know that that's exactly the
language that I want but I do want
candidates to acknowledge at least the
different elements of the path and yeah
I I understand what you're saying
Russell but I think that there's there's
probably more to making that making that
a reality okay for people asking if I'm
going to open up the phone lines I am
open to opening up the phone lines we
were actually we're only eight new
members away from opening up the phone
lines we are alive on both YouTube and
twitch and we
we have two different we have two
different coupon codes that are
available we have one that's YouTube 50
which will save you 50% we have one
that's switched 50 if you're watching on
YouTube use the YouTube one if you're
watching on twitch use the twitch one or
forget about all of that crap and just
use the coupon code last 20 19 which was
our Black Friday special it's the last
big membership drive of the year and
it'll save you 60% forget about 50%
it'll save you 60% and if eight or
actually no Makayla McGonagall just
signed up that gets us to eight and
let's see I I love my new thing where I
can move the bar here it's gonna pop
there it goes
we're now update so if seven more folks
sign up I will open up the phone lines
but in the meantime let me just play a
few voicemails that have been coming in
despite the fact that we are not opening
up the phone lines quite yet people
continue to call in and I got a lot of
emails last time I did this that people
liked hearing some of the random
voicemails oh we have not heard from
Jimmy from Philly the crazy Trump
estroux used to drink but now does LSD
LSD we haven't heard from him for a
while and he left me a voicemail so
let's take a listen to that david kimba
from kelly I just watched her trumpet
explains why Trump is perfect what what
a bunch of [ __ ] David is gonna be
him other Democrats mm-hmm if you have
any sense at all David you know damn
right well no one in the Democratic
amongst Democratic candidates have a
snowball's chance in hell of beating
Trump you know this and yet you continue
to spend your [ __ ] I can't wait to
the election David David I am going to
call you night and day around the clock
and Trump wins you're gonna be so sick
of me you're gonna block me okay
so that's Jimmy from Philly listen I
don't know Joe I don't know why Jimmy's
arguing with me I agree I think there's
a really good chance Trump wins
re-election I'm not arguing against
Jimmy from Philly III that this is why
I'm so concerned so so no disagreement
here III think that there are candidates
that can beat Trump but it's it's quite
plausible that Trump will be reelected
trust me I I understand thank you to
everybody who's been renewing their
twitch Prime subscription over on Twitch
I do appreciate it we are now in month 5
of our twitch experience and a very
special experience I would call it and
so we do have folks who are now in month
five of twitch prime Val McGlinchey has
subscribed I already mentioned five
months it's year one
gurpgork subscribed for five months with
twitch prime so thank you so much if you
have Amazon Prime and you are watching
right now please consider using your
Amazon Prime subscription to subscribe
to me with twitch prime for free it
doesn't cost you anything I've got a
bunch of other questions here from via
super chat but before I get to that let
me say thanks to Jake Robinson Jake
Robinson is new member number nine of
the evening which gets us very very
close there it is very close to opening
the phone lines just six more let me
answer questions from super chat ryan
nawicki the decline of the Republican
Party is plain to most given the average
age there should be a drop-off soonish
how do you think the party will fight
this unfortunately Ryan
they are fighting it already by really
pouring money into things like toilet
paper USA also known as turning points
USA and these on sending ben shapiro to
campuses sending charlie cork to
campuses sending candice blow ins to
campuses and all of that stuff they
invest money the left either doesn't
have or opts not to invest money and
unfortunately the problem with that is
that it is going to bite us it continues
to be problematic for
left and so I don't think that the
demographics of age are actually going
to cause as much of a problem for
Republicans as one might as one might
imagine but thanks for the question Ryan
via super chat on YouTube QQ - s says
$27 for Sanders canceling a $200,000
Hillary dinner only to have the
regulatory committee accused Sanders of
cheating grossly unfair in spirit of $5
psh
right okay thank you I appreciate that
white death nine says are you concerned
about potential self-censorship given
that tick-tock is controlled by the
Chinese government
oh yeah so we made a tick-tock account I
mean listen almost every platform we're
on does stuff that we don't like I don't
have to name them but that's just well
yeah I just pulled up my tick-tock page
and it just went completely crazy we
just get on any platform and we'll put
our content out there and try to reach
as many people as possible and if
tick-tock kicks us off because of what
we say about Hong Kong or what we say
about LGBT rights or whatever then we'll
just be off tick-tock we're gonna try to
just spread our message as much as we
can so I'm not concerned about
self-censorship I've directed the team
to just post our stuff that's it let's
see here
other Super chats that are coming in
Lance Smith asks oh wait did I skip
somebody no Lance Smith Lance Smith says
what do you think about the Matt
Dillahunty and Dinesh D'Souza debate
coming up in March oh I don't know
anything about that
but Matt is a great guy let's see Matt
Dillahunty Dinesh D'Souza Oh so it looks
like there was an event that was
cancelled last year I don't see anything
about a rescheduled one to be quite
honest yeah I mean if people have info
about that I'm glad to look at it but
I'm not seeing any uh anything about
that right now but I would love to see
that that would be a very very exciting
debate to see let me say thanks to
Giorgio's Quartus Giorgio's Quartus for
signing up at join pakman.com that is
new member number 10 of the evening and
that gets us just five away from opening
up the phone lines we had an
extraordinarily successful membership
drive
we did a Black Friday membership special
and we had let me get the exact number
as of right now let me see the exact
number of people that took advantage of
that membership special to 29 to 29 our
most successful membership special thus
far and you can keep building on it
if you want because that coupon code is
still available its last 2019 so thanks
to the more than 200 people that signed
up very very much appreciated ok let's
see
on March 1st 2020 Matt Dillahunty and
Dinesh D'Souza will sit down in New York
City for discussion two people who agree
on very little knock locked in a battle
of ideas that cuts right to the heart of
who we are and who we were going to be
if someone's trolling me with that then
you've done really really well
oh no let's see I found a video about it
let's take a look we have seen in in
recent years not just atheism but a kind
of New Atheism more more militant more
suave a more effective than than the
atheism of the past they want to attack
Christianity in the private sphere also
they really want to make every christian
feel like a total idiot increment a
scientist explain why there's a monkey
that can sit next to you and you look a
whole lot different sure because we
didn't descend from monkeys monkeys and
humans descended from a common ancestor
I was a fundamentalist Christian for
more than 25 years and thought that I
was supposed to be a preacher he gave
some good advice and some crappy advice
and some questionable advice and that's
not enough and there's not a secular
humanist organization or country on
planet that has ever produced as a good
thing an intentional good thing rapists
and murderers Donald Trump is is an
outlier he he is unusually flamboyant
he's brash well I'm super interested in
this it looks like yes March 1st 2020
our friend Matt Dillahunty
will be debating Dinesh D'Souza and that
that actually seems really great I look
forward to that and it it looks like
it's going to be a great great
conversation let me see here let me see
what I think I might have missed a super
chat no I didn't okay very good so we're
caught up I appreciate that
let me also say thank you to Jose got a
SIA thank you so much for signing up on
our website that is new member number
eleven of the evening and that gets us
to within four of opening up the phone
lines highlighted message over on Twitch
David did you see that Rania Khalek of
Russia funded in the now called you out
in a video about Bolivia posted eleven
thirty your clip appears at one twenty
eight hundred no I don't I mean I don't
care I haven't seen it and I've we're
sort of well beyond that story at this
point and I'm just too busy to be doing
you know responses to stuff like that
but I didn't I did not say it sounds
compelling though very very compelling
let's see other questions that came in
oh thanks to Jimmy tenpins for
subscribing for the second month in a
row with twitch Prime Jimmy says Trump
is not well thanks for a great show
David appreciate that
Peyton Pell and says I am a chef knife
maker and I rely heavily on social media
for my business what are your thoughts
on discussing politics publicly as a
small business listen Peyton so here's
the thing that's gonna be your call
right if you believe that discussing
politics is so important that you don't
care if discussing politics hurts your
knife business then go ahead and do it
if you make the decision I mean you're
not you're working in knives not in
politics so I don't think there's
anything wrong with you
saying I have my politics but I just do
knife sales and I'm not gonna bring
politics in I think that that's totally
reasonable my thoughts are that I have
no problem with small businesses telling
me what their politics are as long as
they are prepared that they are prepared
for the reality that they may lose
customers as a result of that they may
also gain them right there's no question
but that's a call once you cross that
once you ring that Bell
there's no unring that Bell so to speak
particularly because the internet
remembers Dave rest asks via super chat
what would you say to someone who's
apprehensive or skeptical about Medicare
for all for fear it will be horribly
managed for example like the VA well
what we find out is that when you
kneecap programs they often don't work
well and so what we need to do is ensure
that it is actually properly funded and
that I have no concerns about it being
properly run as long as it is properly
funded Matthew Dominguez says where do
you think Mookie Betts will be traded to
I really couldn't say
I really couldn't couldn't tell you
unfortunately I'm unable to say all
right let's listen to a couple of other
voicemails here this is a weird thing to
be stuck on let me go back somewhere
else you know there we go maybe to this
we're listening to just a few voicemails
that have been coming in we are standing
by we may open the phone lines we're
only 4 members away from opening up the
phone lines we have we are live on
YouTube and twitch we have a code
youtube' 50 which you can use for 50%
off if you're watching on YouTube we
have a code twitch 50 which you can use
for 50% off if you're watching on Twitch
and then if you just want the biggest
discount and you don't care about this
twitch versus youtube thing then use
that code right there at last 2019
that'll save you 60% forget about 50%
it'll save you 60% let's see who else
has been leaving voicemails and then
hopefully I'll get to talk to some
people live momentarily here we heard
from Jimmy from Philly already let's
listen
[Music]
from actually Wellesley Massachusetts
and local just wondering I just don't
understand why you dislike ben shapiro
so much i think that he's spreading
disinformation but I don't it's these
things aren't personal very militant
towards the trans community and things
of that nature but he just seems to be a
guy who understands you know logs can
facts and a reasonable understanding
over arguments and you seem the exact
same breed well I'm gonna say great but
you understand what I mean
who fun getting very unison Shapiro
I don't think okay that's enough I don't
have any beef with Ben Shapiro sometimes
he says things that don't make sense and
I talk about them and I criticize them
and that's it okay let's take a listen
to oh I see a four and a half minute
voicemail anytime I see a four and a
half minute voicemail I get scared let's
take a listen I got to tell you this my
last message I was very insulted all my
family's in Puerto Rico the only reason
I live in New York because I have two
daughters here man this is barely
audible and now there's a whooshing
sound and it's five minutes long so
we're gonna skip that one let's take a
listen to Angie I had a question would
you consider possibly a debating hunter
a balloon this has been something that
has been curious about for some time
there is a video that I just saw it was
asking about the same question so I
wanted to pique my interest and ask you
would you two say debate hunter alone be
reason that's the question from the
video the other day I said I don't know
who he is
my team has advised me that he is a
prominent youtuber and I would consider
debating him if the topic made sense or
or something like that let me say thank
you to Blake Daniel Blake Daniel is new
member number twelve of the evening
thanks very much Blake we are now just
three members away look at how close the
lighter blue bar is to filling the
darker blue bar I do think we needs a
little more contrast there so I'm going
to suggest that before the next stream
but we're only three members away from
opening up the phone lines yeah I don't
know I mean hunter Avila Ville Valo nav
alone maybe I don't know j-money J sent
me a super chat saying hey David looking
at the Democratic presidential
candidates in your opinions who would
you say is most likely to win and
potentially go against Trump judging on
their debates so far well I don't have
any special insight into that I mean we
have the polling and Biden Bernie and
Warren are the three that are leading
and you know Pete Buddha judge has been
surging from behind and it's possible
that he will continue to make headway
but it seems like other than the four of
them I don't really see a path for
anybody else right now
Alex sent a twenty dollar super chap
Alec says ar-15 is the rife it fires
5.56 by 45 millimeter NATO a Ruger
mini-14 can also fire the same ammo that
would do the same amount of damage same
rate of fire it's not the gun it's the
round stop with the ban of ar-15s people
are so uninformed oh geez that's uh I
hope that that was worth twenty dollars
for you Jay that was crazy but alright I
mean listen I agree Alex
so listen I I'm just kind of joking you
are right Alex that things are more
complicated than just banning a gun but
your argument is almost about it looks
like we need to expand that idea rather
than then retract it but I don't want to
turn this all into a gun stream but this
is certainly not a gun stream people
asking what is oh I should address that
people are asking what is the where did
that video go where's the orgasm video
was it back here no it wasn't okay well
there's a video of I think Erin posted
it yeah trump pretends to have an orgasm
during a during a speech let's just
listen to it four people joining late
here it is
eighteen minutes after the oath of
office months earlier Peters struck
remember he and his lover
Lisa Paige water group
she's going to win ten million to one
she's gonna win and I'm telling you
Peter
here goes telling you Peter she's gonna
win Peter oh I love you so much and then
after the crowd claps he's encouraged
and he does more
this is the sick I love you too Lisa
Lisa Lisa Lisa oh god I love you Lisa
yeah here it is
if anyone's gonna be familiar with what
it's like to be in a room when there's a
fake orgasm I think definitely it would
be Donald Trump so in that sense it's
not surprising let me say thank you to
man John Smith sent me the super chat
have you read the book democracy for
realists it's a recent book by two
political scientists who suggest that
most voters are not informed or rational
I have not read it yet but it is on a
list of possible future interviews so it
is a book I I may I may soon soon read
yeah I mean I don't know what to make of
the orgasm video it's a very strange
video for sure thanks to flat-broke
for subscribing with twitch Prime I
appreciate that very very much flat
broke thank you so much let's listen to
a couple of other voicemails here we are
just three new members away from opening
up the phone lines we can do it we could
have the phone lines open in a minute
folks
believe you me we're looking at it very
very strongly let's take a look at let's
take a look at this one uh hello David
Pakman I was the caller from the five-30
area code a couple days ago I kind of
stumbled a bit when I called cuz I'm out
the autistic so I I was a little all
right we're gonna move on I don't want
things to get a little bit strange here
so let's try a different caller here's
someone called me 40 times in a row and
left 40 voicemails do I even dare
actually I'm not gonna mess with that
either cuz this is all live and I have
no idea that that just it seems
problematic so let's skip that as well
let's try a different voicemail like
this
hello Holly from California well I'm
calling because I had okay I don't know
what that was I may have missed one or
two words but it also seems like it
would be better not to uh yeah we're not
let's not do that okay let me see if I
have anything else it is a weird batch
here
hello David my name is Dan started
watching your show earlier this year
I've followed Young Turks and just found
your show very interesting my question
for you is with all this talk of civil
war under the trump administration where
do you think it will lead do you think
it's just more talk from conspiracy
serious that we've heard from the past
or do you think that they might actually
come something I mean if you think about
the mag a bomber and people do
atrocities and Trump's name do you think
that this could progress into something
worse yeah I actually fear that it could
and I've been talking about this more
and more lately I actually do people if
you haven't heard that there's talk of
civil war then that's good you're
probably staying away from some pretty
toxic media but yeah look up this guy
Wiles who was talking
right on today's broadcast show and it's
really really crazy it's it's it's scary
and and what's also scary is that so
many people are there by even while
being outraged about it they are still
sort of pushing it and it's very
concerning it's very very concerning and
I am scared I'm scared whether Trump
wins or loses but particularly if he
loses in 2020 I'm scared that there is
going to be significant significant real
world violence the ben shapiro thing so
I got another super chat about ben
shapiro where kelly d says ben shapiro
only cares about winning a damn debate
with his technique I wonder if he
believes his own words waste of time to
my ears so this is actually something
funny someone sent me and there wasn't
really a place for it on my broadcast
show but I've talked before about how a
lot of what ben shapiro does is that he
talks fast alan Kaepernick's what
someone told me was if you slow it down
by putting it at point 75 playback speed
you very quickly realized that he's not
actually saying things that are that
interesting nor even that insightful
let's just test it let's just go right
into the middle of his pro today's show
today and see what it sounds like at
point 75 point 75 yoke and population
not broken down by race but broken down
by politics and that is deeply negative
it's why you see people like Colin
Kaepernick being granted all sorts of
endless media time for his for his
virtue signaling stupidity run a wide
variety of topics so for example Colin
Kaepernick over the weekend well again
so what's funny is this is actually the
normal talking speed for more people
like Ben Shapiro's normal talking speed
is really fast and a lot of people are
influenced by that this is Ben Shapiro
at what we might consider more of a
normal talking speed and it's less
compelling as it retains his fame only
because the media keep covering his
various anti-american protests whether
he's putting pigs on his socks or
whether he is saying that the Betsy Ross
flag is racist
well his latest bid for attention since
he obviously doesn't want to play
quarterback in the NFL all right so I
think people get it it's
you know if you slow it down a little
bit and you can actually think through
each thing that he says it's it's much
less much less compelling for sure
thanks to Daniel Krieger for sending a
$2 super chat with the message love you
Bibi thank you so much I also want to
say thanks to Hugh J Mis for subscribing
for two months with twitch Prime you can
see the real difference between the the
usernames over on YouTube versus on
twitch subscribing for two months with
which Prime I appreciate that
and somebody tricked me saying my sound
was on me and kin3tiks for subscribing
with twitch Prime as well I very very
much appreciate that a lot of people
asking are the phone lines open and I
see that people are calling and like
crazy the phone lines are not open we
are very close to opening them we have
12 of 15 new website members that join
pakman.com all the information is there
and if we get three more we will indeed
open up the phone lines if not don't
worry we will be live-streaming the
impeachment hearings later this week
which will be an opportunity for phones
we will be taking phone calls on
Wednesday and Friday it sort of seems
like it'll be so there's gonna be plenty
of opportunities to call in but I'd Lee
would open up the phone lines this
evening if if things happened David can
you speak as quickly as possible for 30
seconds I I just don't I don't even know
how we talk that quickly that that's
basically as fast as I can go it's just
not natural to me just put me at put me
at 2x actually maybe I should even try
that let's see what I sound like it 2x I
don't think I've ever listened to that
well this is like recursive we've got
we're streaming the fact that this
stream is happening let's take a listen
what do I sound like at 2x
here we go contender for the most
delusional Trump voter in the coming
video in the United States last week
during a livestream that I did on
youtubes which we happen to overlap with
some of Donald Trump nagger rally in
Florida and Fox News sent a reporter
actually let's call an attack with a
microphone I think there said they sent
a gobby microphone to a restaurant in
Boca Raton Florida the day after the
rally and they happen to come across a
business owner of a security company but
it's also profess I don't exactly own
security buddy who hires lots of
veterans who says he used to be a
Democrat but is now fully back in Trump
this guy says he is all that's actually
not it's it's not unintelligible let's
now try me at point seven-five all in
with Trump because he's patriotic and he
supports Family Values and he's honest
this is Trump and has integrity of
character and has delivered on his
promises I see you today
the man that might be the most
delusional Trump voter in the country at
least a top contender writer that
position okay I think that 1.25 might be
making me sort of like ben shapiro right
and notice as you watch this video how
sure of himself this man seems to sorry
what's your name Andy do front who has
had not only endless affairs and seems
to barely even know some of his children
but as paid off some of his mistresses
was involved with people whose names I
can't even say because as soon as you
say certain names you get any monetized
on you too but I think you all know who
I'm talking about those Family Values
Trump's Family Values have this voter
gushing over Donald Trump he's with
Crump over alright so there it is I
didn't know I think that okay so now
let's go back to the normal trumps
honesty Trump is the most dishonest
president it sounds slowed-down weirdly
right now yeah I think I 1.25 doesn't
make me sound normal that's weird maybe
I need to be talking more quickly that's
uh that's that's pretty scary stuff okay
let me say thank you to Lance
Smith says Ben Shapiro says John
Lennon's song imagine is the worst song
in human history and calls it a very
immoral
I'm actually learning imagine on the
piano right now Alex with a 300 dollar
super chat blowing everybody else out of
the water
sorry not aware guns were too off topic
I'm a big fan of your show and love to
support I don't disagree with expanding
our idea of gun control all I'm saying
is when Democrats talk about guns they
are so clearly uninformed that gun
owners don't take them seriously and end
up voting for Republicans I'm from Texas
trust me I actually agree with this I've
said before if listen this is why I did
the story about do you understand the
obstacles to medicare-for-all because if
you don't then you are not going to
convince people that you actually know
how to implement it and I think that the
same thing applies to a lot of people
when it comes to when it comes to guns
as well
totally agree there appreciate the super
chat Alex thanks very very much let me
say thank you to Daymond Wells who has
subscribed via twitch prime over on
Twitch we are live streaming on both
twitch and YouTube and we are
considering we are considering opening
up the phone lines but we still are just
a few members short let's see what else
did I want to go over oh okay yeah I had
a couple of other things let me pull
them up here actually oh and there's
also another voicemail that came in
let's take a listen to this hi David I
have a question
so the Bernie bros are unwilling to vote
for Biden and possibly even warn if
there's a neither of them is the nominee
and Buddha Church but in 1989 the
Democrats were willing to vote for
Michael Dukakis even though some of them
were I hard to see Jackson's supporters
to grant it I would add if I were alive
I would have been a die-hard Jack
Jackson supporter not I probably I'm
gonna be Jesse Jackson fan because he
has a disgustingly anti-semitic man he
would have bought it from Michael
Dukakis because at least he's for you
know 75 or 80 percent
of what the primary candidate was for
also in this case we have a president
who's an imminent danger to the world
and we need to do something thanks David
all right very good that quite
comprehensive and actually making a lot
of a lot of good points yeah okay people
asking about the title which is about
Trump faking an orgasm yes we we've
already played it twice so I'm not going
to play it again but it was it was it
was pretty disturbing I'm not gonna lie
cliff allure says just want to say love
your work and respect your knowledge was
just curious about you joining that
Jordan Peterson app or whatever keep up
the great work much respect oh yeah I'm
gonna have a video about that soon so
let me and in fact maybe by the end of
the week
so let me table that but there will be a
video from me about that before you know
it and it'll be a very very strong video
that's for sure it's gonna be it's gonna
be an extraordinary video I predict okay
alright there's folks saying hey you
know David you should just open up the
phone lines because a $300 super check
came in forget about three more members
that's fine all right you've convinced
me let's do it
let's let's open up the I'll take a few
calls I don't have a lot of time today
but we will take a few calls 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 I am opening up the voicemail
right now I'm gonna get myself connected
to it and then I'll be able to take a
few calls thank you for calling in to
the David Pakman show
please do not use speakerphone have a
question ready and listen for David to
call out your area code very good 6 1 7
8 3 0 47 50 is the number you can call
in and talk to me right now if you want
let's go first to Sebastian from Texas
Sebastian from Texas what's on your mind
hey there David how you doing good how
are you I'm all right I just want to ask
you a couple questions since you're in a
you know on the youtubes and whatnot
I've heard from a couple people
recently that you know that the
impeachment is really not as important
leads to the public as something like
the current Democratic you know election
that's a primary election that's
happening right now now I was wondering
from your perspective do you think that
it's true do you think that people are
not as interested as impeachment as they
are about the democratic elections
should people be more interested in the
appeasement process especially since we
know it's never going to go through the
Senate these are two different things so
so here's the reality Donald Trump's
actions warrant an impeachment inquiry
so we should have won it shouldn't be
you know Devin Nunez kept saying during
the hearings last week or the week
before all ratings are down for the
hearings it doesn't matter the the facts
warrant an impeachment inquiry so we're
having one and then we'll figure out
what the next step is totally separate
from that if you don't think Trump's
doing a good job then you should be
aggressively involved in the Democratic
primary and getting ready to work on
that it's it's like a walk and chew gum
at the same time thing these are two
different things and I just disagree
with saying one is more important than
the other one is an election that gets
scheduled every four years these
elections are scheduled and that's
really important in addition we have a
president whose actions warrant an
impeachment inquiry and we have that and
both are fine okay cool
do you do you see how how is burning and
warring gonna do if they get called back
to the Senate and not having to be out
there you know um you know campaigning
while they're sitting there through
impeachment meetings which is what what
like six weeks or something
I think that they would be fine I think
they'll figure it out and I think
they'll be they'll do just fine okay I
would definitely call it Libya is
definitely not a coup you guys just
because the ice video got so many views
I don't know what's up with that David
it was weird
everyone's talking about it and they
were all up in there and they were like
oh yeah you're the best David I don't
know what they were talking about I'm
sure was all positive I'm sure it was
all positive you know but
Sebastian what are you talking about
your video thing where you're like no
one's paying attention to what I'm
saying
or something or whatever okay all right
Sebastian thank you I don't know what
Sebastian is talking about but it just
it just mere did something just go
totally off the rails there let's go
next to our caller from the five one six
here I'm a little rattled by that last
call five one six I apologize I'm gonna
regain my composure for you now you're
good this is Dan from New York I'm Laden
so hope you had a nice Thanksgiving
David I did thank you you're welcome
I was just wondering I'm not like super
familiar with tulsi gabbard
or like her entire like record I guess
in the public eye I know she was pretty
outspoken in 2016 about the DNC and like
what they did with Bernie and whatnot
but listening to a lot of his videos I
kind of get the impression that you're
not a huge fan of her maybe I'm mistaken
but it seems like sometimes you kind of
like flippantly mispronounce her name I
could be wrong but I was just wondering
if you could maybe tell me a little bit
about her perspective and why she might
I know why she's not popular some people
in the establishment but I was wondering
what your personal opinions are you know
I've got so many clays in this that I
don't really want to do another clip
about why am I not supporting Tulsi so
let me approach it a different way
there's lots of candidates I'm not
supporting I did a clip today about why
I'm not supporting Pete Buddha judge
I've talked before about why I'm not
supporting Tulsi Gabbard so I'm like a
warren Bernie guy that's where that
that's who most aligns with my politics
and those are the people that that I
would like to see be the nominee to be
clear I don't mean supporting her
specifically because I don't support her
either I support Bernie I was just
wondering what about her that people
might not like on the left because she
seems like she I guess from my
perspective she aligns more with
somebody like Bernie than others but I
could be wrong so I was just curious
like genuinely curious about her
that might cause that but I is there any
particular video that you could
recommend that I could look at for a
more clear more clear information on
that I don't have the links in front of
me but if you just go to my channel and
then you just search my channel for
tulsi gabbard you'll find a wealth of
videos alright great thanks a lot all
right thank you very much let's go next
to the caller from the eight one four
area code who's calling today from eight
one four eight one four eight one four
are you there we can we can hear you
yeah I can hear you I'm sorry how are
you I'm doing good I had a question
another to do the flip on it awhile back
to go so I was looking at getting into
the insurance market okay and when I
went to an interview for one of them my
office had about a hundred people and
it's not a really big town and with
Medicare for all which is something I
obviously support so I didn't take the
job with automation and healthcare I
feel like we seriously need to consider
what's gonna happen one of those jobs go
away right okay go on so obviously I
feel Yang's a little bit politically
crazy at the time of his UVI type of
ideas I'm just wondering I mean you
already said it's not very politically
feasible for Medicare for all but as a
future step what would you think might
be something if we succeeded and that
policy proposal what would be aesthetic
for what
the employment of the individuals who
would lose their job because it oh yeah
listen I mean any any policy any pot any
government policy has an effect on
employment and so it's very popular for
people who are against Medicare for all
to say but what about all of those
medical billers and insurance fraud
investigators and insurance salespeople
or whatever okay I mean every policy has
some pros in some cost everything is
weighing what we get and what we lose
and in this particular case they're
gonna have to find new jobs and I don't
I can't tell you right now what those
jobs are going to be but this you know
we're we going to hold back the
development of the automobile because
the horse buggy drivers we're gonna be
out of a job it seems crazy now to think
that that's something we would have been
able to do you know what I mean oh yeah
I'm definitely not convinced by the fact
that those jobs are worth more than the
collective but it's just between truck
drivers and a bunch of other people who
may soon lose their jobs kind of a
societal question I was thinking about
yep well it is a good one it is a good
one and I don't have the exact answer
you may be looking for it today but I
appreciate the phone call very very much
let me say thank you to RAF Times who
has subscribed with twitch prime over on
twitch no more super chats over on
YouTube that's sad
let's pick up next on let's see Oh Val
from Agawam is on we haven't heard from
her for a while hey Val what's going on
hey David how are you doing good good
hope you had a good Thanksgiving I did
hope you had a good Thanksgiving
yeah I wasn't bad the turkey the turkey
always there's questions like is the
turkey is it cooked is it not cooked you
know that game everybody does yes
exactly
yeah and who's cooking and who's
cleaning up sure I'm sure the time time
old are you more into the are you more
into the cooking or the cleaning up or
neither exclusively the cooking yeah
okay good
I was wondering what you thought about
since you are a Bernie slash Warren
person like you were doing what your
thoughts were concerning his rallying in
Massachusetts do you think it's really
important for him to come and have a
physical presence here since it is such
a Pro Warren area to some degree you
know I have to tell you I really don't
think it's important and I know that
there's a lot of discussion about
Hillary ignored Wisconsin and she should
have gone and this and that and okay I
mean I may be for people who are more
casually following what's going on that
does matter but honestly for me I don't
care I don't really care where they go
because I'm not going to any of the
rallies I'm not interested I'm going to
be making decisions based on policy
positions and and what they publish and
what they say in debates so I fir I
actually don't care but in the sense
that it matters in politics then yeah I
mean he probably should she he can go
anywhere that he thinks will make a
difference for the primary results sure
right no I was just curious I I guess I
kind of agree with you that I think most
people will not be going to the physical
rally and I know unfortunately there are
a lot of Donnie's supporters here around
Agawam feeding Hills area yeah I feel
like I'm kind of in the minority but I'm
trying to spread the progressive word
yeah it's weird because Western I mean
Massachusetts in general is pretty left
and the Pioneer Valley in western
Massachusetts is very left but there are
these enclaves once you get closer to
the Connecticut line and then also into
some of the hill towns which are
surprisingly conservative and it's
always every time I'm reminded of it
it's it's a little bit disturbing yeah
hopefully it's gonna be changing right
let's hope so all right well thanks for
taking my call all right thanks Val
we'll talk to you soon valve from Agawam
shot out of a cannon
they for sure back from the holiday
let's see let's go to uh so Tim's asking
to get on Tim was on speakerphone last
time he called but alright Tim Tim from
407 I'm putting you on
hey David can you hear me
yes I can could you I learned my lesson
no speaker so thank you I'm a big fan
and like you I am very concerned about
the general election and the way I kind
of see it is like the current for
frontrunners which would be Biden Buddha
judge Bernie and Boren they are the way
I see it is we're kind of flipping a
coin you know it's in terms of can they
be Trump in the electoral college and I
don't really need to go down the reasons
they all have their flaws so to speak
sure that is but I was curious as to
what you thought about yang if he was
the hypothetical nominee how he could
potentially fare against Trump I don't
pretend to have any special insight into
that I would just look at what the
polling says and I don't I don't have
recent polling in front of me of
hypothetical matchups I know that there
are yang supporters who very strongly
say he is the only person who could
actually be Trump I don't think that's
the case I don't think there's any
scenario in which yang is the only
person who could be Trump I think
generally speaking if the 2020
presidential election swings against
Trump there are lots of people who could
beat him as long as they run reasonably
good campaigns and I think that if we
don't get the vote out then I think
Trump's going to get reelected and it's
not going to matter who the nominee is
so I don't have any particular sense of
Andrew yang as a guy who would be
specially positioned to defeat Donald
Trump I certainly agree that's why I say
like it's kind of like flip a coin I
definitely don't think he's the only
person that could beat Trump I think
they all could you know depends on kind
of how things unfold but I kind of see
yang as like a he would energize young
voters for a large turnout like you
you would take a decent chunk away of
Trump supporters and have a pretty good
appeal to independence and then see
which is actually a wild card that might
sound cheesy but I think at the end of
the day I find it very difficult for him
to lose electoral college to the point
where people are going to say no I am
NOT going to want a thousand dollars a
month I just don't see that happening
because it's not like the way the way
perception is with like medicare-for-all
and cancelling student debt like it's
easy to kind of propagandize those
positions if you will and label them
socialistic but people know what cash is
it's it's a lot harder I think to say no
I'm not you know I'm not interested in a
thousand dollars a month I mean what are
your thoughts on on those couple points
I just laid out listen if the thousand
dollar a month thing was so
overwhelmingly compelling he'd be
polling more than three percent so I
think you're maybe overestimating that
well no I that's a fair point but I just
think when you actually have to pull the
lever you know yeah it's kind of like
how many people are let's say if we're
in you know minor thought-experiment
Social Security has not been implemented
how many people are in favor of
implementing Social Security you know
probably not too many but now everyone
loves it when when they're like an inch
away not just getting pulled but an inch
away from actually pulling that lever to
receive the cash I just again this is a
hypothetical this is my I mean we'll see
we'll see if people when it gets time to
pull the levers as the primary start if
they go and pull the lever for yang
right I mean we'll actually we'll be
able to turn it from a thought
experiment into a real thing that's very
true I too much I got another quick
question so I know you call yourself a
Bernie Warren guy if yang was polling at
similar loved levels would you consider
yourself a yang Bernie Warren guy or
listen I would vote for Andrew yang if
he were the nominee but I I've talked
about I've talked about yang a lot I've
interviewed him three times and there
are some policies of his that strike me
as
sort of lacking nuance or maybe naive to
some degree but let's not turn this all
into all about yang so Tim I appreciate
the call I'm going to let you go and on
that note I'm actually going to cut the
stream we're gonna cut the stream right
now because I do have to run we will be
back with a full day's